sin ha reaccionado y con indignación al
reciente anuncio de que el caucus
desarrollara armas hipersónicas esa
decisión ha aclarado y el ministerio de
exteriores chino sólo aumentará la
proliferación nuclear y la carrera
armamentística por lo que todas las
naciones de asia deberían estar alerta
los misiles supersónicos vuelan a una
velocidad que quintuplica la del sonido
y además a diferencia de los balísticos
lo hacen mucho más cerca de la
superficie terrestre por lo que son
mucho más difíciles de detectar y de
abatir sin ha sido muy crítica con el
autos desde que fuera creada en
septiembre del año pasado es una alianza
de defensa en la que participan eeuu el
reino unido y australia a pekín ya le
indignó que la organización fuera a
dotar a australia de submarinos
nucleares y últimamente la mencionaba
como un ejemplo del expansionismo
militar estadounidense que pone en
peligro la paz mundial la otan del
pacífico' así la calificó china durante
la reciente visita del presidente ruso
vladimir putin a pekín en la que ambos
países se comprometieron a fumar un
mundo sin políticas de bloques ni
mentalidad de guerra fría en una clara
alusión a eeuu